a system which has helped us to manage
the arrival of more than twenty five and
a half thousand refugees into the UK in
the last year including more than 2000
unaccompanied children the council's
have taken in but there clearly are some
sticky issues that need to be worked
through as we look at how we scale up
the scheme which is currently brought in
around 200 Syrian refugees to the point
where we can bring in 20,000 and having
seen the circumstances which some of
those people are facing in the
information we've been passed by the
Home Office it's clear many of them have
very significant health needs very
significant disabilities as a result of
injuries that they've suffered due to
the civil war in Syria and so we need to
make sure that there is appropriate
accommodation there are school places
for their children and that the NHS is
geared up to provide the care they're
going to need once they arrive in the UK
you've described their sticky issues as
you call them what exactly are those
points specifically that that need to be
addressed what the first is funding we
know that the government has announced
that there will be money available for
the first year to help resettle people
into the UK but they will be coming with
a right to remain in our country for at
least five years so we need to work out
how the the costs of the housing and
schooling and all the other things that
they will require a paid for and the
second big issue is making sure that we
can match the office of accommodation
which are coming in from any local
authorities and from the public with the
needs of those individuals so for
example a man who I'm aware of who has a
wheelchair as a result of injuries that
he suffered who's in a household with
six other individuals will clearly
require appropriate accommodation
including accessible accommodation so
that he can access it so in order to
make sure that that's available when
people arrive we need to make sure that
there's a proper planning process and
that will involve local authorities that
do this kind of thing day in day out
with people who find themselves in
difficult circumstances in the UK so
that we can extend that to people who
may be coming to our country from Syria
and obviously all of that is going to
cost an awful lot of money can you
foresee battles to be fought with
central government or government are
going to be fighting their own battles
as they go through a comprehensive
spending review and clearly they're also
making the case of the European Union
that because this is part of an
international effort money could be
found from some of those international
resources as well the key thing for
councils is that we need a commitment so
we can be clear with our communities
they're not being asked very unfair
burden because there isn't just one use
funding being made available there will
be money to ensure that those people
half the school places the NHS care in
the accommodation that they need beyond
you one beyond year one then what though
what the commitment we're asking for
from government is to ensure that
there's funding available to support
those people for the time that they
remain in the UK now many will come to
the UK because they will have the right
to work and find themselves getting jobs
settling in as part of our economy and
being able to support themselves but for
those who come with very significant
care needs the cost burden for which
will fall on public services like the
NHS and local councils we need to make
sure there's a plan in place because the
last thing we need is for the media
agenda to move on and for local
communities to be feeling that they're
now asked to pay an unfair burden and do
you have confidence should that 20,000
mark be surpassed that there will be the
resources to deal with the people coming
in well I personally had conversations
with ministers in the last 24 hours I'm
very clear that they're committed to
finding a resolution to this now clearly
it is going to be difficult because we
all know that there isn't that much
money to go around in the UK public
sector at the moment so we need to find
a way of doing this as efficiently as
possible but this kind of work is
business as usual for councils we've
managed a forty percent reduction in
funding while still supporting many
vulnerable people in our country
including those refugees in the two
thousand and accompany children who've
arrived every year year on you it
because before Syria of course we had
crises Afghanistan in in parts of Africa
so we can fix this situation but we need
to make sure that the funding and the
resources are there so it isn't seen
subsequently as an unfair burden